If you never wrote any program in Python, here is
some advice on the specifics of Python. If you
know your way around Python simply skip this
segment. To indicate that the rest of the line is
a comment, simply put a # in front of that line
to create variables simply type the name and
write equals whatever you want, you do not
specific the type of a variable, unlike in C or
in Java or in C++ or in C#, Python is
going to figure out the type on its own, like
Javascript if you will. So that’s an allowed name.
answer = 42, radius underscore of underscore earth
is an allowed name, 6.371 times 10 to the 6.
I’m writing comment M to say meters
by just simplest way of indicating what the
measurement unit would be. And you must not
start names with digits: 13test, too is not a
correct name. The print command, print out,
what you’ve given after it, very simple. If you
want to specify more things, simply use commas.
This now shows some basic arithmetic’s advantage
I wrote it first
for us to discuss the results. 42 is assigned to
answer, 6.37 something times 10 to the 6 is
assigned to radius underscore of underscore earth,
now we do some computation of three times
answer plus four and the result is assigned to a
variable called A. Note that multiplication and
division are executed before plus and minus.
Now we take the radius of earth to the second
power. Asteric asteric (**) represents the power
operator in Python unlike C, unlike Java.
Parenthesis work as they work in school and
again the power operator 0.5 of course meaning
this is the square root, that’s one way of
writing this square root of A+3, the result
is assigned to B. See this is what our output
here. The second one gets pretty ugly. The
content of answer is incremented by seven.
Plus equals seven, that’s the same as in C and
in Java and in Javascript. The increment operates
on the same work for minus equals time equals
divided equals. What you can’t do is plus, plus
unlike C and its sibling. If you want to do plus
plus you have to write plus equals one. This again
is similar to C, if you divide integer numbers
five divided by four, the result is an integer
number. let's look at up. C is the fourth one
one, two, three, four.. 1... 5 / 4 is 1
in Python as is for C and for Java and so on.
If you want to see a floating point division at
least one of these two numbers has to be of
floating point numbers, simply write 4. (i.e., 4 dot)
d.. Let's look at the second to last.. 1.25.. it works.. or 1.0
times five divided by 4, Python starts from the
left as does C, as does Java 1.0 times five is
a floating point number that’s divided by the
integer number results of floating point number.
Keep that in mind, there is something that easy
leads to not so obvious errors. There is more to
mathematics than arithmetic’s. To do more we
need to import the math library. This is
done best at the start of a program when we need
the square root, we then can then write math.sqrt(4)
which actually is the
same as four asteric asteric 0.5, if we need the sin
function its math.sin parenthesis, the angle.
Of course this angle is specified in radians,
not in angular degrees. To convert from angular
degrees to radians multiplie by pi - math.pi,
it’s a built-in constant, divided by 180.
If lines get longer, we may need to break the line
to keep it readable, if there is an open
parenthesis, you can break at any point then
sometime close that parenthesis. If lines get
longer, we may need to break them to make
things – to keep things readable. Python is picky
about lines. You cannot break anywhere; that’s
unlike C and Java. But if there is an open
parenthesis you can break anywhere. Python
is going to wait for that closing parenthesis.
For the standard mathematical functions, such as
square root and sign, we need to import the
math library. This is done best at the beginning
of a program and then you invoke the square
root for instance by typing math.square root and
the argument is given in parenthesis. That’s
pretty similar to Java and to C#. The result,
of course, is 2.0. We could also have written four
to the 0.5 power. The sin function is math.sin.
The cosine would be math.cos and so on. The
constant pi is included as math.pi. The sin
function and it's friends work with radians,
not with angular degrees. So if 23.4 is an angular
degrees, we need to convert it. For instance, by
multiplying with pi and dividing by 180. If lines
get longer, you may want to break them to keep
things readable, Python is picky about line
breaks. That’s very much unlike C and Java. You
cannot break a line at any place, but if there
is at least one open parenthesis, you can
break the line. This is what I’m using here.
If you need something to be done a given number
of times, you can use the 'for' loop, which looks
quite different from C. The first thing that you notice
is a colon at the end, no braces, but a
colon here, at the end of the first line, and
indentation. The indentation and that colon
replace what C users know as curly braces.
What happens here? h starts with 0, gets 1,
2 and so on and at the end its 6 and then the
loop terminates. So you do not write 'for h =0;'
and so on. h < 7, you write 'for h in range 7'
That’s the Python way. So if we look
at the result... so it prints out square numbers
starting with 0, and eventually terminating at 6
to the second power. The 'while' loop is good for
loops that run as long as something has to be done.
So in this case, this loop runs as long as K is less
than 130 or M is equal 140. So unlike C, you do
not write '|| 4', you simply spell out 'or'. The same for &&.
Don’t forget the colon, so
we see that K runs up to 130, this first
condition fails and the second one is not
true either because M is 7,000 something.
Now to conditional execution - if the value of K
is larger than 42, don’t forget the colon,
output 'Hi'. The text string and single quotes
and 'elif' – that means if K was not larger than
42, check if M is larger than 43. If so, output
'Hello', if not which means if M is not larger than
43, output "Buy". And of course K is larger than 42,
its 130. So we output "Hi" and never see the rest.
The 'else' is optional and the 'elif' is optional.
We need to work with long lists of data. This
package called numpy; it comes in handy, yeah.
numpy.zeros creates a one dimensional array and this
case with five entries numbered from 0 to 4, like in
C. Here I change the entry number 0 and here
I change the entry number 4, which is the last entry.
I print the complete array and here I print the
ultimate entry. This comes in very handy and is
different from C and other languages. So the
complete array contains 20,0,0,0,99 because I
changed the entry number 0 and I changed the entry
number 4. And the entry number if you will, minus
1 is simply the last one. Often we do not get
away with one dimensional lists, we’ve to use
two dimensional tables. This creates a table
that’s filled with 0s and has two rows and 3 columns.
Here I change the entry that’s in the upper row,
row number 0 and in the middle column, column
number 1 (column is ranged from 0, 1 to 2) to 7.
And here I change the entry in the lower row,
the rows are 0 and 1 and in the right most
column to 8, I output that. And then I do some
arithmetic’s with matrices that is we’re
going to cover that later, one plus twice
the complete table that I built here.
Let’s look at the output. So, that’s our array.
0,7,0 is the row number 0. 0,0.8 is the row number 1.
We changed the entry second column,
row number 1 to 8. Thats this guy . And
here I computed the one plus twice the array as
above. The 7 becomes one plus two times 7,
15, the 8 becomes one plus two times 8, 17.
This again is something that you can’t do with
regular arrays and C or in Java. This comes
very handy for mathematics. And there is one
more thing that resembles arrays in C and
arrays in Java, if you think you copy that array,
you didn’t actually create a copy, you just
created a reference to the very same thing in
memory. So yeah, it seem to create a copy Q
equals P, I changed the copy to make the left
– the top most left entry equal to 42. And then
I output P and you see, if I look at P its too has the
value 42 in here. There is just one instance
of that array in memory; both Q and P refer to the
same instance and memory.
This is how we define functions in Python. We say def
function name, the parameters that we want
to hand over to the function, colon and
then comes what the function should do.
Again, of course, with indentation. And you call
this function like you call math.sin and other
build in functions: with parenthesis, similar to
C and Java. So in this case U is set to 1,
we compute two times U, R becomes 2
and we return 2 plus 1 equals 3 and then
this case its 7, U is set to 7, R becomes
14 and we return 14 plus 7, that is 21.